I feel like I need to calm down
I'm not fluent in French I'm not even
like broken English French I actually
don't know much of French besides being
weak I was introduced to the French
language on my life because I'm actually
Haitian but unfortunately I never picked
it up so when I hear a man do one just
know that I is a good language I love
the French accent because it just sounds
like someone is singing to me like it
feels like an R&B song keep that R&B
silky smooth voice in my ear telling you
sweet nothings about how I pleaded my
teeth like I don't care I'm so excited
to start this challenge I mean I haven't
heard your French accent a long time so
I would love to have a French reminder
and these men better be cute I know I
can't see them but they better be cute
mr. Franz
my name is Sedona su I'm Mr Francis top
oh my god say my name again there are
general management economic policy
management better
don't be something more city of Doha at
least thought I could do hope you don't
get so nervous really know I look good
did you say I'm good booty come on teach
even love into the sunset
oh yeah I hear that passion yep often
once the consider to cleaver has
violence from the Louis Vuitton member
on go 12-hour luck he to China
[Music]
Parvati Lucille ha
before it caught this power
like what what's happening we can't come
out a bit we like to see brisk his
posture again what will tsunamis such F
could require any limits quick music oh
you're asked me if I like music I like
music
let's get that music right great great
Oh Drake say no homo just say that more
how did you make Drake sound expensive
mr. Cameroon hello I'm David I'm mr.
Cameroon oh should we break down ye
that's gonna come over in the pear to
rob a casa y k liy do
conative why don't sue me me me haunt
you verse 20 bail a convict accomplices
the marks they sue us to combust a
combination of plaza merci beaucoup
beige Chola we say you're giving me a
chocolate or you're calling me chocolate
either way I'm fine with either answer
TM unison yeah Jim a romantic comedy
those are great student athletes
[Music]
mr. Haiti it's the kid courtesy aka dad
Austin man would definitely everything
but also known as mr. haven for today
which is yeah
now down some won't survive at the end
come on - a bad voice hello
like I said came in come or just a shame
the biocomposite you did assuming that
we're welcoming came not back Cunha che
there's like some Sun Basin couriers
there's some there's some spice in this
version some Yamanashi material
community to find
geniality as the players women so this
is mr. Jackson is it of France this
French accent is summer house and I in
Salem do that once I'm up somebody that
I'd be induced Meserve by oh no men do
by le mo mo to go Yamanashi alguien es
where tsunami I say not my my my my I
swear to be my so I live in a Haitian
household so this what are you saying is
very familiar
I can I can pick out certain things that
he's saying he is very confident in what
he speaks to me
he's basically spitting game like any
man I guess would in this instant
I think I'm imagining him with like you
know a button-down shirt half button
then he's just kind of like you know
that guy on the street that's like
what's nothing mom and you're just like
oh my god like hey but if it's endearing
because he's very funny
the three French accent that I was
dealing with are all different which was
surprising to me like the first one
looked a little bit more like suave
leading man romantic
accent with somebody who you imagine in
life those romance novels that's just
trying to sweep you off your feet and
he's just like giving you literally just
like fairytale vibes number two his
voice was like a little bit more bad-boy
like it was definitely still like
romance cream French but like I just
felt like we were about to get into
trouble and I don't want to get into
trouble the second one is kind of like
the nice boy next door who just kind of
like wants to get to know you and
doesn't want to push any buttons and I
would say for number three I just felt
like you had the most unique or
different accent compared to the other
two and the third one is like the bad
boy who's gonna say how he feels and
like put it all on the table
so in terms of the sexiest I think I
have to go with number one I think
number two I think the bad boy raise
your hands ha you were hilarious oh my
god I don't know why this is so
nerve-wracking I like getting flustered
all over again who is number two who is
my bad boy French accent it's funny cuz
you look like a bad boy here you you're
wearing white you look angelic
[Laughter]
[Music]
you